so welcome back to the asked coffee hour
we are really excited to have on zach
king today he's got 66 million followers
on tick tock being the fifth most
followed person on the entire platform
and he's got 12 million subscribers on
youtube he's been on tv shows movies
you've probably seen him online and he's
about to reveal how much money he makes
are you excited i am beyond excited are
you
i i am but did you subscribe i
subscribed so hard hey everybody i'm
zach king welcome back to the iced
coffee hour and guess what this podcast
is made up to this date
72 thousand dollars
that's under guessing wow you under
guess what i understand yeah okay yeah
let's let's re-guess um then if it's an
under guest then probably 265.
now you really really only get there now
we're honing in it's like it's 180. oh
130. 123. that's great yeah 123 000 yeah
i mean
you guys know this but that's some
people's whole year income yeah and
you've done it in about a year and a
half so that's pretty impressive yes we
are but i know for you guys it probably
feels small
not for me no not for me okay yeah it's
pretty first am i allowed to ask this
but what's the split on the chin like
have we ever we've never disclosed this
publicly
that's gonna be expo
should we should we just start it off
with a banger should we disclose that
i'm i'm okay with it i'm okay with it
yeah you're okay with it yeah i'm fine
with it i've always wondered i never
heard you talking yeah sure this is the
first time yeah ever and this is across
the board between sponsors and ad
revenue everything that the this channel
generates and all the expenses are split
with this number so i get 99 jackets two
percent yeah
wait 99 and then two percent yeah how
does that is it ninety-eight
no uh it started out i think i had like
in the beginning what fifteen percent
i think it was twenty no it was fifteen
and then we moved it up to twenty
because you saw how much work i was
doing with each episode providing the
outline and everything yeah and then
when i dropped out of college
that was it yeah where's my outline oh
your outline yeah i don't think you did
it uh yeah yeah we don't do that anymore
i have to cut his mission back
so i got lazy we had it okay so it
started at 20 15. it started 15. those
first few episodes were just jack and i
talking and jack would come out with a
list of questions to ask me and it was
just him and i for the first like two or
three yep each episode was probably
taking me at that point like 12 to 14
hours okay just between the planning
which would be like the pre-planning
would be like three to four hours just
literally just researching like fun
money quizzes and stuff like that topics
we can discuss uh and then also like
recording was an hour and a half or so
and then editing it took me so long
editing your podcast it was insane yeah
so probably like 12 to 14 hours and he
saw how much work i was putting in so
he's like i'll bump you five percent so
he's making an extra like 70 bucks a
month pretty good so it's everything the
channel brings in whether it's
commission thing or adsense yeah at the
time it was really just adsense and we
had no expectation this was just jack
being like hey if we spend an hour a
week all you got to do is just show up
yep and i'll see your cameras yeah yeah
i was like okay for an hour a week we'll
do this we'll get out of podcast and
then and then it started growing a
little bit and then when i dropped out
of college i requested a larger portion
of the second channel which i i do a lot
of work on that uh and graham one he
didn't want to give me that larger
portion so he's like the channel is the
gram stuff stefan shop yeah so we
decided to roll that into the iced
coffee hour so he's like i'll give you a
huge portion of the iced coffee hour and
a smaller portion of this that i know
little did he so back then
this podcast was making nothing it's
probably like 700 bucks a month maybe
that but jack was spending like 20 hours
a week just like just through
miscellaneous stuff i was spending
probably about two hours a week between
titles and thumbnails uh it was taking a
long time so that was uh basically a
part-time job for both of us
and uh yeah so i ended up giving jack
you want to say it 45
whoa yeah yeah whoa that's awesome yeah
i wrapped it up and that's very that's
generous and then as soon as he gave me
45
the channel exploded it was so it
him 45 thinking oh you know it's right
and i calculated how much money i
thought the podcast would make and it's
like okay well this is compensating jack
for his time yeah and then within like a
few months after that we started just
loaded it up with sponsors like sponsors
it really isn't so you're going after
the sponsors yourself uh i was back in
the day but now we have like a few
agents oh i was organizing all the
sponsors i still do yeah but well alex
yeah even when you have agents you're
still mad like checking all the balls
yeah absolutely and you're reading the
contracts and yeah yeah you have to be
the you know agents we found over the
years are awesome when they get to know
your brand you know i rep by caa and we
do brand deals directly too with brands
but it's that's nonsense you're still
even if it's going through an agency or
another agent you're checking everything
right check cause it's on you like if
something else got in there exactly to
say or whatever it's important yeah but
uh yeah i mean
now i would probably have negotiated
stronger but
you know
he didn't even want to continue doing
the podcast back in the day yeah there
was there was a point for me where he
literally wanted to quit yeah i was so
busy and this room is like i don't have
time to do a podcast i just i can't do
it yeah i don't have the time and joe
was like no we got to do it i was like
well we had done like seven episodes
before i didn't want to miss an episode
so it was just
wanting to continue that because i
didn't want to like do seven and stop
nice
yeah i think it's super important that
people have skin in the game they're
excited and they have ownership over it
yes
and now you can just run it i mean
you're basically plugging and playing
into this right at this point no now
yeah guess a lot and then you do title
thumbnail the guess makes sense because
well like i met you uh you know in la
recently it's like that happens right
you just meet people exactly and it's
like it makes sense for you to kind of
book it doesn't take too much time yeah
but yeah so those for us are good
networking opportunities because
it's different when you're like dming
people back and forth and it's it's not
the same as like getting to meet
somebody in person totally especially
someone if you've been watching them for
like two three years you finally get to
like interact with them in person it's
so much fun i'm so awkward about that
though it's like you go to all vidcon or
all these different events and you watch
people for so long and you kind of
become a fanboy or you know of their
channels yeah and then you meet them and
i like i freeze up i'm like really a
little bit totally no say say some names
say some names everybody like
anybody me i met graham the other day um
at the the ping pong thing yeah and it
was like uh like i just forgot no yeah
yeah totally it's weird it's weird
meeting youtubers like being in the
space but like who who shocked you the
most who shocked me the most because for
you it's like you were probably one of
the biggest youtubers i've ever met
certainly you're probably the biggest
person we've had on the podcast but i
like watching so it's everybody i watch
i'm like when i meet them i'm like a
little bit thrown back you know yeah no
i feel that yeah i watch like a little
bit in the you know find like what i
listen to on my drive i have a long
drive in l.a so i listen to a lot of
finance stuff because you guys actually
make long form like this you know
podcast not everybody does that um so
like i'll be star strike to meet andre
i'll be starstruck to me are you meeting
them we've seen we've dm'd but you
should meet them all here you'd love to
know
next time i will next time because i
want to spend time with you guys
um right answer like andre and uh and
kevin yeah like i mean i listen to kevin
every day me too at some point during
the day so
he's like right down the street from me
too yeah but i feel like
one i think he's super busy like i don't
even want to dm him to say let's hang
out
we briefly killed him no because i've
seen he
does he sleep i don't know no like three
hours a night yeah yeah that's insane so
i feel like it's taken away from family
time or like some sort of he i here's
what i picture you're hanging out with
kevin he's like dang we hung out for an
hour and a half i could have made two
youtube videos
you know i could have no you would not
believe it we were playing poker over at
jeremy's house and it was like it was
like it was like midnight probably and
graham's like all right dude i have to
go home like i gotta get some sleep you
know gotta work tomorrow kevin's still
there he's already down three grand in
poker and then we keep playing two am
rolls by and he's all right you guys
going to the club 2 a.m yeah 2 a.m and
the next morning he probably woke up at
six and pumped out seven
videos live at six yeah yeah it's like
it's insane yes kevin will find a way to
make a video with you during the time
that you hang out yeah it's either with
you he'll just monetize that
conversation or he'll be like wait i'll
be right back and he'll be outside for
10 minutes recording a whole video he'll
upload it it's nice you don't even
notice yeah in one tank and it's like a
fully scripted post-production pipeline
i have no idea i've you know seen his
tour of the i think it's in a garage
still no it's a room and he's actually
okay oh he upgraded to a room he's
always happy he's always had a room yeah
that's still impressive that he hasn't
gone out to like a studio never um it's
all one room in the house his room by
the way is smaller than this that's
amazing yeah that's incredible yeah my
myspace is like
it just doesn't
translate to a room i wish it did that'd
be awesome yeah we want to hear about
what you're doing though because i have
to say it's it's very impressive across
all the platforms like you found a way
to dominate like instagram
tick tock youtube your youtube channel
by the way fine yeah that was never the
master plan though like i never wanted
to go after right at this point when you
look back doing this for 12 years
started on youtube it's gone it's always
added them slowly you know and then some
don't stick around
there's actually so many that don't
stick around that you don't really like
my my idea uh is always to be on a
platform first and see if there's
anything interesting about it like with
vine it was the six second things and i
kind of wait now i try to get there a
little before my friends are talking
about the app
um but in vine i was like way behind i
remember that was even a thing like when
i got on nine months later and it blew
up for me a lot of the other viners were
like well you're not an original viner
and it's so funny how that like
nuanced conversation is gone for
platforms now but back in the day it was
like if you weren't on it within a year
you weren't the og of that platform
um but it's been bouncing around
platforms like youtube was my first love
i started with tutorials so like uh you
guys don't have a monthly training or
master class or any of that final okay
oh wait we have a monthly you guys have
a month you have a mentorship
group shout out to them yeah there's a
coupon code down below
um
so you have is it monthly yeah yeah so
like i was kind of doing those but like
making my own site for final cut pro and
teaching people and that was my business
like youtube was my business just with
that monetization aspect there was no
adsense when i started um and then i
think a year after i started my channel
there was they were rolling out secretly
or privately the uh invite to the
partner program
um when you guys started youtube you
could just sign up right like you could
do the threshold oh yeah you're
monetized basically immediately yeah i
think they monetize people who don't
even ask anymore it's just you're rolled
into something right but you don't
receive the money oh is that right yeah
yeah they now youtube has the right to
monetize any channel they want to and
run an ad but they could they'd have to
tell you right
and i know i believe can you just by
default by default i think by uploading
youtube you i mean you're giving them
the right that just recently changed
right isn't it yeah yeah a few months
ago so i have like 1 700 subscribers
and when my family watches my videos
they get ads but i don't get any of that
right oh interesting but first i want to
thank our sponsor front
jack what are you doing on your phone
man
dude i'm just checking my robin hood
portfolio i'm buying the bitcoin dip
that's great and all but why are you not
using front it's the ultimate companion
app to robinhood weevil coinbase and
more it basically shows you all your
investments in one place wait so you're
saying if i download front i can see all
of my investments with all of those
different brokerages and exchanges in
one place exactly that's amazing not
only that jack but it actually gives you
a unique front portfolio score it
basically sums up the health of your
total portfolio within a single number
and the ai that gives you the front
score actually takes into account
diversification asset performance
company financials and much more plus
front shows you the top stocks to
increase your front score so you can
build a stronger portfolio and there's
even a community feature where you can
follow your friends portfolios and see
how you compare to them jack i'm
actually gonna follow you on front and
every time i see your portfolio's up i'm
gonna ask you for lunch alex you can't
say that i already said i would do that
exact same thing to you so if you guys
want free lunch just follow alex on
front his username is apple pie and
anytime his portfolio is up just venmo
request him like 10 bucks or something
so go ahead and download front with the
link in the description down below to
see how your portfolio stacks up today
that's right guys you can see all of
your investments all in one place on the
easiest ui ever so that's front thanks
front for sponsoring this episode and
back to the podcast
kind of makes sense that youtube is it
would be smart yeah
i think there's probably i would love to
know the calculator how many videos are
out there that typically wouldn't get
monetized because they're not a creator
hit the threshold right that's right i
have a feeling what it is the ad rates
are getting so high on certain certain
channels that they need to spread them
out because otherwise advertisers are
going to get to a point where this
doesn't make sense but if they have
twice the channels now to advertise to
they're getting twice the exposure yeah
yeah i just jumped around platforms year
like youtube i loved it but then vine
took off and it was like i was still
running like one man show had just hired
my first producer to help me with the
vine stuff but the bandwidth was like
going to vote year was this did you go
to college i went to college yeah i did
2008 through 2013. oh the recession the
great recession that's when i would have
gone to college by the way if i went was
2008 yeah i went to college and i paid
through college with those training
courses so i started my channel like
that freshman year of college
and it's because i didn't get into film
school so i needed like an outlet to do
i was still doing music but i really
wanted to uh
pursue film i knew i like film was going
to be my end-all career
um i was kind of lucky to know that but
i was teaching the final cut pro stuff
at night i was doing tutorials and live
training and that's how i was paying
through school and selling dvd courses
and then eventually um
right when amazon launched their cloud
service i uploaded all my stuff my
courses digitized them and started
selling them through paypal and uh i
think there was like a
uh not venmo but another like weird
case or payment service and uh i did
that all the way to graduating college
um
and then the first year out of college i
think it was when is when mine came out
and that really i was already making
these videos they weren't like if you
look at my videos now you'd say that
they're you know i describe them as
magic just because it's simple and
that's what everyone's like oh yes i
know you're talking about um like jump
in a car and you kind of phase through
and now you're in that item
so
that was really a spin-off of like my
vfx training that i had learned and
taught myself in film school
and vine because it was six seconds it
just forced me to like figure out how to
like make those in a short story that
had a beginning middle and end and like
had a good punch line was really visual
and that's like how that format that i'm
known for now really was birthed but i i
love the constraints of limitations like
it's kind of crazy that on youtube there
used to be a ton of limitations like it
was for a while 15 minute videos and and
it slowly grew and now it's like what
unlimited yeah i think 24 hours isn't it
yeah yeah but i i love the constraints
still like it would be fun if youtube is
like this month you can only post three
minutes or whatever you know you can't
do that now they're too big but you see
every platform like slowly when
instagram was the thing it was like 15
seconds and then they upped it to 60 and
then 90 and then 120.
um same with tick tock now i don't even
know what their limit is now three
minutes is it three minutes
yeah nobody watches a three minute well
do sometimes people do the three minute
videos give you the option to skip
around yeah so that's their thing
because sometimes i've seen i hate these
videos there was one where it was like a
a river and take talk and it was like a
minute long and it was just like wait
for it and then after 10 seconds you're
not going to be two minutes yeah yeah
and then the whole thing wasn't getting
too long
watch part two no i'm like oh yeah
i clicked but this video had like 10
million views on it so i figured like
it's got to be good and then they just
have high retention literally them like
throwing a brick over the side it's very
satisfying but but it wasn't that it was
just a brick i mean it was like what you
would expect you could also chop that
into 10 seconds yeah you're like dude
you were you knew your retention tricks
right that's funny so at least through
three minute videos they don't hold you
to that for three minutes you could skip
and be like well this sucks yeah so
you're saying that the time constraint
on vine being six seconds kind of taught
you how to condense like very exciting
content into like short i love time
constraints i absolutely love them it's
like
one of the you know i think when people
think creativity they think oh like well
i want endless i want no rules i want no
boundaries i want to have like endless
space to do my art but people um
especially young creators i always tell
them like when you're making something
go on the weekend your goal is to make a
30-second thing or a 10-second thing and
then go whether you want to publish or
not that's on you
but that's the iteration you need is
like ideally start shorter and then you
can add up the time that's fascinating
and now i think like to the other viners
that then made it to youtube like logan
paul and jake and like david dobrik
they're all very like quickly cut yeah
right it's very condensed uh content
yeah maybe they learned it from vine but
it's done them very well yeah i think
because they know what holds attention
and they know what makes a good story
and it's funny like being with um when
you're with logan or david when they're
you'll go with them
and then
you'll
they'll be at events and not show it
like they'll be at these awesome events
and not show a piece of it like be at a
premiere i remember
premiere with uh david and went back in
the vlog the next day and was like oh i
wonder what how much that he used and
none
and it's because to me i was like
that was pretty entertaining right like
you could use a piece of that nothing
it's like
you gotta cut it and i think like great
editors know when to cut stuff out too
like it's like you know they call it
killing your baby um in editing in
hollywood like a lot of directors get
attached to
the certain shot they got they spent
they remember being on set all day
getting that really cool dolly shot and
they want to use it but if it's not
adding to the story or taking away from
a moment you've got to be okay to cut it
wasn't it david dobrik or someone was
talking about him being at like a tesla
event and like there's something big
that happened and he didn't use any of
it just like you said yeah i could
totally they're like that was like the
the coolest thing i've ever seen and it
didn't even make his video
of that week yeah which i mean that's
yeah that's a lot of youtubers you know
that know really to trim the fat
and uh i think mr b jimmy's great at
that yes oh yeah you see them shoe and
half over half doesn't make it in it's
about 95 i would imagine yeah by using
like a sliver of the day right i've
heard that like mr beast's his like
total gigabytes that each video occupies
is like several terabytes i believe it
like per video yeah and they cut it down
to like you know 13. especially the
videos where they have like 100 gopros
you know on individual people and i
don't know i asked them that was the
first question i asked him like who is
going through that and he was like yeah
our do we have editors but like he was
like usually it's two editors a video
i'm like oh my
but to me that's is that a lot to you
that's little to me no that's very few
yeah yeah i would imagine like ten yeah
but then again communicating between ten
i feel like it would lose that feel
that's like two people themselves doing
it all would know every bit of it versus
ten so here's the trick i learned um
being on i was on a show called the
amazing race with my wife a couple years
ago you were you were on this show yeah
were you traveling
yeah it's a great show i watched as a
kid growing up with my family wow and so
did i on them to let people know who
don't know the show the amazing race you
go around the world you're hunting for
clues and you you know go on these
different legs of the race and you're
trying to get to the finish line of
these multiple day legs
and what i learned is you know they're
obviously capturing
terabytes and terabytes footage from
multiple teams every single day but they
have a producer go with you a story
producer and the producer like is not
affecting the game at all they won't
give you they don't even know what's
happening but they have just in their
notes a little app that has a time stamp
and they're just saying like you know
zack and rachel fight at whatever uh
this time over this clue that's it and
they're like rating these story points
so the editors you know you're not i
mean maybe that somebody will go through
everything of course yeah but really the
main
even assistant editors will just skip
through most of it and it's same with
jimmy's videos or all these reality
shows like they don't need to go through
everything as long as they've got the
story producers there just giving the
time stamps it's so much easier you know
cuts the good stuff that's incredible
and so then all the story producers meet
at night after you check into the hotel
or whatever that leg of the race and
they'll all just kind of compare notes
like was this team who had the most you
know kind of drama let's like seems like
and like they're not changing it in the
edit that's what's amazing to me i
always wondered because i was a fan of
the amazing race like are they like fake
making up this drama and like editing in
a way that made it seem way worse than
it was or is the order actually accurate
in the edit but it's like 100
true wow uh and so that's why i had a
lot of respect for that show and i think
survivor's similar in that way i think
it's pretty fairly accurate to what
actually happens
that's incredible but first we have to
thank our sponsor masterworks guys the
stock market has been going absolutely
insane lately and now inflation is at a
30-year high i don't know about you but
i want to invest some cash into
alternative assets to hedge against
inflation you know jack if you ever want
to invest in my buy alexa lunch fund i'm
always taking new people you know alex
with inflation soaring you're going to
need way more investors than just me to
fuel your uber eats addiction you're
probably right on that one but i do know
of a new investment that actually is a
good hedge for inflation thanks to our
sponsor today master works masterworks
lets you access an asset class that
outpace the s p 500 by 174 from 1995 to
2020. and it also has the lowest
correlation to the stock market of any
major asset class according to a 2020
report by citibank and this might
surprise you guys but the acid i'm
actually talking about is contemporary
art see i've heard about people
investing in art before but don't you
have to be a literal billionaire to do
so see that might have been the case
until now thanks to masterworks people
like you and i can actually invest in
some of these multi-million dollar
paintings at a fraction of the cost and
here's how it works masterworks team of
analysts are constantly researching
which artists work provides the best
risk adjusted returns for you to invest
in this includes names like warhol and
picasso and this means investors can buy
shares of the art just like you and i
would buy shares of apple and tesla in
fact last year investors got a 32 return
on a painting by banksy so if you guys
want to add these electric assets to
your portfolio check out masterworks all
you need to do is click the link in the
description to get started now thank you
so much masterworks for sponsoring this
episode and back to the podcast
so through college you paid for it with
these with these programs which college
did you go to i went to a school called
biola university out in uh fullerton la
morada california okay yeah and how much
was it
oh uh expensive school yeah yeah i was a
private christian school i was probably
30 000 a year so
120 000
can you say how much you were making
then with this like uh the mentorship
program that you have i made just enough
to cover school so you're making a 30
grand a year or 40 probably yeah
probably and then adsense kicked in i
just recently looked too i was like how
much will they make an adsense it was
barely and you know i was definitely in
the ramen days of of college my thing
was like chicken wings there was you
guys know albertsons yeah yeah so they
have albertsons out here um they had
like a really good chicken wing lunch
deal i ate every single day it was that
and i would have [ __ ] for dinner for
like seven dollars and fifty cents there
you go and i was like 750 was splurging
for me yeah yeah
yeah so that was my
my college meal and it was like every
day like
everyday chicken wings so you're
probably making about 40 grand a year
yeah how much of a falling following did
you have at that time um i had at most
on final uh 200 thousand following that
was your live youtube channel at the
peak before i left divine and i remember
like within three months of vine i'd
already passed it to like almost uh
half a million on vine there was a point
where the it actually back you know like
platforms don't really grow your youtube
that quickly anymore but back in the day
if you said like from your vine account
if you had a couple million followers
you're like hey go follow me on youtube
it would just shoot up yeah and i never
took advantage of that i always was
nervous about cross-pollinating and it's
the game is totally changed on social
media now now everybody wants to
cross-pollinate because it's kind of
hard to get that conversion but back
then i never wanted to i was actually
really weary of collabs i never wanted
my following to be from you know
king batch's audience i didn't know like
if they would stay with me or if they
were just following for that one collab
so i actually wish i took advantage of
collabs earlier like it was something i
think it's a it's a great it's a huge
strange way to grow yourself yeah it's a
huge way
um but it's actually slowed down a lot
like
if i were to shout you guys out or
you're shouting me out it's just slow
like it's not like back in the day you
would be like if i shouted you out back
in the day with the following what's
back in the day 2013 13 okay like maybe
if what i don't know uh what do we have
now um you might get like a million
followers somewhere
you know but that doesn't happen anymore
like it might be like 10 000 right yeah
like so it's there's no conversion right
so did you decide to pursue any sort of
normal career after college or was that
your queue you're making 40 grand a year
you got a good following i did i um i
had a great offer because i was making
40 and then i think somewhere i was
probably making
60 000 uh on the training courses and i
thought like okay that's a great i could
make a living doing that i could grow it
slowly too and i had all these ways to
like do different courses and kind of
spin off i was only focusing on one
software and there's way more software's
coming out adobe cloud is getting pretty
popular at the time
um
but i
didn't i got a job i did a road trip
with my buddies
before youtube video we wanted to like
make a video in different states and it
was kind of like a content trip
and so we spent like 40 days going
around the country and in washington dc
i stopped the discovery channel we had a
fan reach out it's like hey i work as a
producer at discovery channel you want
to come hang out and get lunch at the
cafeteria and so i went in there and it
was my first time in like a corporate
kind of film
tv building and i met one of the high
rep producers and they made us a job me
and my buddy a job offer for over six
figures and and it was super tempting
like my channel was looking at like ah
one it's youtube i don't know i mean
it's so easy to look back now and be
like oh yeah youtube was the obvious
front runner and the good decision
decision but
i was really conflicted like i remember
calling my parents on the drive back and
it was the drive back was like five
thousand miles so it was like slowly
talking over the next couple weeks as we
were making our way back to la like
should i do this interview in la that i
have to do for discovery and so i i
ended up doing the interview and it was
such a like a blessing in disguise
interview because me and my buddy go in
we had a great interview my last
question for the guy he was like do you
have any more questions for me like
for he was like the head la branch guy
and i was like okay would you if you
were me would you take this job and i'd
explain the youtube thing because i was
really conflicted i was like my youtube
channel has maybe i think i had 200 000
followers at that time but i wasn't
making great money it's like 1200 a
month on adsense so i was like i don't
know if like i can actually get married
and have kids with this
so
he was like i don't know like youtube uh
is an interesting space i think he had a
lot of great insights he was like i
don't know if i would take that
yet
and he's like what's the risk of you i
don't know playing this out another year
year and a half two years i was like oh
there's there's no risk i'm meeting pha
i can afford that
that's it yeah so all you need really
yeah that's all i needed and so luckily
that like decision i walked out that
meeting so peaceful i was like yeah i'm
not gonna take this me and my buddy
looked at each other and he and started
a channel at that time too which is uh
do you guys know aaron's animals
bro dude yeah
yeah so he started his channel at that
time too so we both have kind of changed
directions with our content or we do you
know just you just animal stuff i do um
the magic stuff but both of our channels
are like kind of equally successful um
just because we
put the time in
but that's amazing and that's crazy to
me too because you had like 200 000
subscribers but you're making forty
thousand dollars a year it's like
nowadays if you have two hundred
thousand subscribers you're golden yeah
basically on youtube
well for some channels you know i think
really if you can pull really depends
you guys are in the
finance space so i think you're you're
skewed but uh if you have a good engaged
audience with 200 000 views yeah i think
in any niche because you could at least
have sponsorships affiliates like there
are other ways that you can just market
your audiences yeah business i think the
training course aspect is still highly
interesting um i don't do it anymore but
i'm jealous of the people that have an
obvious like oh yeah teach that that
makes sense
right so you're building out this thing
over the next year
at what point you begin to realize that
it's like a significant amount or at
what point for you is it like all right
i'm all in like this was the right
choice
i mean i was all in at that point yeah
um what i wasn't sure of is how to ski i
think the hardest part for creators and
this for me back then
and uh what i see now is it's hard to
scale yourself because you're figuring
out like what part of yourself you need
to scale is it like you're editing is it
your writing is it your production time
is it for me a lot of it was like the
set building took a lot of time in like
trick engineering and i enjoyed that
part but it was like what what part am i
good at and for the first one i had to
let go was like the editing of the
videos um so i started training editors
like okay here's my exact style like
here's how i make these cuts in here so
i here's how i shoot them and this is
why i shoot them that way
um
and it's not like anybody can't reverse
engineer what we do but it's just like a
specific
kind of angle of how we shoot it and
edit it
but like i had to let that go and you
know the thought i had in my back my
head i think so many creators have is
like oh i'm the only one that can do
this i'm the only one that's skilled
enough to do this or i'm like i'm the
only one to know when to cut because
that's my style i know he's looking at
you
yeah
why is it so hard to let go
uh because i'm worried that that's like
that's that's the personality of the
channel is that at least for the main
channels that everything is done by me
so every word you hear from me is
scripted by me every topic is picked by
me yep um i film everything myself it's
and i like the aspect especially in
finance that it's just it's a guy in a
room talking to a camera by himself
doing all the work and there's something
i think that's really authentic about
that yeah that once you start
outsourcing things and trying to
streamline things you just you lose that
feel
maybe
um okay let's take jim cramer for
example
i don't know if you like jim crane right
people have mixed feelings about jim
crow some people i'm just saying because
he's a general finance person that most
people on your channel
dave ramsey sure like dave ramsey let's
talk about dave ramsey
what is dave ramsey's
like why do people follow him for his
advice
for him so like nothing about the
editing no
nothing about the production value
it's like all those things are standard
correct that's what i think so like
uh
that's where i'm coming yeah
cares who edits it i do because i think
uh half the video or honestly i think of
the video i think 20
is knowledge or 20 is just what the
information is the other eighty percent
is entertainment so throughout my script
i try to keep it entertaining i try to
like throw in jokes or make comparisons
that people might think is funny and the
editing is very visual so i like to
throw in little jokes and things here
and there that i feel are important to
the viewers
here's what i think you'll be surprised
to find i don't know if you've ever
reached out to fans but i think um we
actually just put a job posting for fans
um because for many years i was like
against working with fans i thought it
was weird because you know when we had
hired a few fans like they get really
excited they're overly excited to be
around you
but after like after six months it dies
off they become you know just chill with
you yeah but they know your brand and
style they literally know like some of
my team know my library better than i do
they'll be like oh but we already did
that remember like you did that in 2014
in this one video with uh this person
and i'm like oh yeah we did
wow the jump cut i forgot about that and
that's i'm here's my bet there's
probably a dozen people watching your
channel who are editors
that if you said hey will you edit for
me they actually already are editing
your style one reason they might like
your videos and they understand some of
the humor and so i think there's an
editor i know there's multiple editors
i'll interject i've been teaching alex
yep how to edit those videos yeah and so
what i've been doing this last month is
uh i'll have alex edit my video and i
edit mine separately and then we compare
our videos yeah the next day
and we'll go through them each side by
side and what i've noticed is that alex
is now starting to make the same jokes
in the same places as me yeah so i'm
talking about that's great printing he's
using the same thing that i'm it's funny
you're doing slowly doing it that way
yeah i did that briefly and i was like
why the heck am i editing this twice i'm
just going to use my version i know um
versus there's a point where you have to
let you actually today's video was one
of the first ones that alex did i posted
alex yeah round of applause for alex
let's see how it's good job alex thank
you appreciate it guys it did yeah i
don't know why it didn't do well
initially but i'm hoping it's uh let's
see if it's picked you can't blame it on
alex you can't blame that on alex that's
too much pressure
it's picking up a little bit okay that's
picking me up i think what your your
money sauce is
obviously your your personality but your
insights into topics that you pick and
how you talk about them so you should be
involved in the writing process i even
would totally
uh gamble that you don't need to write
the video so you can just i don't know
the same thing with editors there's so
many writers out there yeah who are in
and i don't want to offend you but
better than all of us like even when i
look at my stuff i'm like there's
writers that are better than me that
have ideas
and so if they can work into your
process where like what if you had a
list of five people that they don't be
in-house they could be fans that you're
like hey guys
make it a competition kind of like
you're doing with alex um whoever writes
the best script will get the higher end
fee or whatever but you say hey i want
to talk about i'm really interested in
talking about this new nft platform or
whatever um or maybe you're not i don't
know like whatever it is boom um
and then here are my three main points i
want to hit for sure uh maybe you have a
specific joke you know you want to make
in it and you have them write that and
then see what is in you know because
there is some fleshing out
in the middle of that the meat that you
probably don't need to spend your time
writing like looking up you probably do
a lot of research right i do
that is i have to really understand to
be able to pick out the points that i
sure are worth emphasizing yeah so
sometimes in my research i'll think i
know it all but then as i'm doing the
research i come across something
different and i'm like wow this is
actually a better angle and i'll
reorient the video about something new
yeah
what if somebody brought you a script
though that said like
you read it and you're like oh man i
actually don't know is that true like
and from there you you like they do the
leg work this big eighty percent
it's hard for me because what i've done
is worked so well and it's still working
so i'm like why try to mess with it
right now yeah that's are you control
freak uh yeah
yeah i would say so but i i don't want
to say it's a control freak i think i'm
very particular and i and i i have a
vision for something and if it's not
exactly that i don't want it i don't
want to do it yeah
i i didn't know about your guys's uh
partnership that you explained in the
beginning but that makes me excited for
you because
i think it empowers him yeah and jax can
be stoked and take on a bulk of the work
and that's what you need to do not
necessarily on the main channel and not
overnight but
leverage dude you got to leverage other
people yeah well that's that's alex you
got to listen to that that's alex's goal
right now for the end of the year i want
to train them perfectly for the main
channel edits so by january 1st i want
to okay is it a thing for you it's a
thing for youtubers though like okay so
what's what's kevin's team like does he
is it's really cheap it's pretty small
yeah it's not just him it's him and he
has two assistants that will help him
with anything they do research
so now they like they just started doing
that but that was like as of a month ago
what about what about andre
just him it's just him yeah yeah you
guys got a leverage but how many videos
is android posting per week twice a week
he's posting twice a week and we're
posting like i don't know 10 times a
week across nine times a week across
like five channels so what and what's
your guys's production team is it alex
is it the three of you yeah right here
this is the performance we are in the
room with the president yeah the three
musketeers everything across five
channels wow
that's what i'm saying so but that's
what i like it's like it's a small team
yeah we we just hang out we're friends
yeah we don't have to be friends with
the new person we bring on
we don't have that that's like that's
usually what that's usually what happens
yeah i think it's really important that
your business doesn't like okay when we
moved into our first studio
we went from house that was
uh 2200 maybe like 1900 square feet
there was like 12 of us jammed in this
thing super family vibes like we were
all friends and then we moved into this
warehouse that's 15 000 square feet our
offices are like we had to we're racking
up like the steps just to walk around to
go meetings and talk to each other it
felt super corporate for like the first
six months in there because we were like
how do we manage this in a weird like we
like being in a house and the
neighborhood and but it what it did is
like help streamline the operations then
we realized like kind of separating each
other and it wasn't just like uh hey
you're right here let me ask you this
question that i really should like maybe
we should set a meeting for and like
think about and talk about
um versus like randomly
kind of interjecting here and there and
it's almost like
the house version is uh when i look back
like it was fun
but it's so much chaos and we were
getting a lot done
but it's like the the warehouse the
studio version allowed us to like figure
out what the like really break apart
what is the process that needed to
happen for the videos maybe you're guys
already good at that in this setting
i think we each got we each got rooms
alex just upgraded this is now his
office he was working in the laundry
room yeah for the last uh eight months
and now he's uh moving hey this is this
is an upgrade this is a huge upgrade
yeah we're all we're all introverted so
realistically we don't go and bug each
other
hey that works out if i want to see
graham um i have to text him ahead of
time like i'll never just barge into his
office and he does the same for me that
might be a good rule i understand that
i'm an effort too i just can't imagine
going into an office that's the thing i
love just being able to walk 20 feet and
it's right there if i need alex i knock
on the door i just love it because you
guys are going to take this clip someday
yeah and
i'm on your side you're like remember
when i said that we're never going to be
in an office
because yeah it's it's
kind of i mean it's kind of inevitable
right yeah like it's stresses how are we
gonna continue to grow with the same
team
why is it inevitable though i don't know
because like i mean okay people and
overhead and obligations then then i
gotta pay either rent or a mortgage on a
place more people to keep track of i
love this wouldn't you be excited to pay
a mortgage on a place though because
you'd be
starting now i just i don't want stress
yeah like i've been trying now to like
have the least amount of stress as
possible and that's a great goal think
about something your goal it is that i
mean that's a sweet i get that
i'm the same too like
payroll and and team members and doing
hr and all gosh i can't yeah you know
all i want to think about is what topic
am i going to talk about that that's the
only thing that i want to think about
yeah that's it but you could you can put
like a great uh relations person
between you like you don't have to be
the person that you know is hiring or
even talking to people and my like i
hate conflict and i really hate anytime
i have to like or back in the day when i
was the one that had to say like hey
here's what you're doing wrong or like
the oh the worst is uh yearly reviews
right like
employee reviews which i was doing for a
long time and now i don't do that
because
emotionally like will take me out of
that for two weeks from what i'm making
like only thinking about like two weeks
i have these meetings that i have to
like
tell people what they're doing wrong or
build them up in these ways um i just
love the collaboration and creating
that's what's fun so tell us about your
team yeah how many people you have
working for you yeah like what what is
involved in behind the scenes for your
operation
so at the studio we have like 20
full-time team that do
the you're already stressed yeah i'm
stressed out all right so you can get
people to manage the team for you
let's see yeah but so a lot of it is a
production team right um but it's
through the whole process so the
beginning is pre-production team which
could be writers um it's development a
lot of the trick development so
uh there's a trick development team
that'll say hey
you know what in a couple of months
let's do
let's do an upside down room that can
like maybe it can turn you guys figure
out how to like if it needs to turn or
whatever and i'll pitch the concept and
they'll go off and like
engineer how that could be done both the
building of it the fabrication but also
like what is the aesthetic visually of
that trick and they might input on that
we'll just meet for a couple months on
that um and that's like the writing
pre-pro and then we have an art team
with the production team
but really it's like this arm of
producers that kind of do everything
from in that process so there are seven
producers that are like
every monday go over all the concepts
that we want to do anyone on the team
even if you're in um like our cfo joins
the meeting for pitching an idea it's
like an hour and a half creative room we
put all we put what's called the t sheet
so you literally draw a t
on one end you put the paragraph like
little two sentences about what the idea
is maybe it's we're at graham's
house and we're gonna do something with
uh bankroll coffee i'm gonna grab the
beans and turn it into coffee and then i
draw a little image of that just so it
can be visualized for people just a
thumbnail
and then write the idea it's called
grams bankroll coffee trick
and we put them on the wall we'll have
you know 50 ideas up there and then at
the end everyone gets two little votes
and just a little smiley face it's not
like for a competition at all but it's
just mark your favorite idea like which
one would you want to watch which one
would you if it was on your feed would
you like or which one would you share
with a friend because that's interesting
and it's just a matter of taste and that
actually gives us a really good gauge
of like usually two or three concepts
rise to the top
and i love that because it's
it's based on everybody's taste as a
group and generally those aren't always
the ones that get made but uh usually
they're the ones that get workshopped
and then eventually there's kind of
light bulb moments in there and we we
make those ideas
so it's like a group writing process
because a lot of people have come up to
me they're like how do you get these
ideas and it's not you know in the
beginning it was me
but now it's really just kind of my tone
and some of my sentiment in there and i
love the visuals and and obviously
polishing along the way but it's really
these the producers that take these
concepts and make them come to life then
once you green light them on to the next
day on tuesday
there's a green lighting process so you
have to have a mock-up video we could
have them quickly go out after a monday
meeting they go out and shoot the video
like on their phone or on a dslr
really rough mockup they're really janky
you can't if you guys watch them you
wouldn't know what's going on but we
understand like the visual language that
they're playing with but it shows us the
framing it tells us if the joke is if
we're doing a kind of a humorous thing
that's going to play off or if just the
trick visually will work
and then from there we sign a budget and
it's off to the races so they have two
weeks to make that what's the budget
what's a normal budget it totally
depends like some of our stuff obviously
the brand stuff
uh we could spend six figures to make um
for our stuff
it it's all over like a lot of it so if
we're using a rotating room which could
cost six figures to build uh we've
already got that and we'll use that for
multiple videos
um
could you explain a rotating room
a rotating room yeah okay so
a
rotating room has been a concept since
like uh
pretty early film days actually like
nickelodeon days but obviously people
know um
inception
the scene where the the room is rotating
and they're
the rooms rotating is how they're doing
it they're running on the walls and it
looks like they're running on the
ceiling so what you do is you have like
a fixed circle cylinder and then you put
a camera here and it's locked to that
room so because the camera is moving
with the room you can't notice the
camera move and that's why you know i'm
able to walk on on the ceiling or on the
side of the wall wow because gravity is
actually changing for me that's crazy
yeah
so those are the fun stuff in the you
know because of the studio space that
we're able to build
so you're saying it takes two weeks to
make a video
on average yeah for what we call like
our personal content which is our main
slate what you guys see as the the
videos that are unbranded that's what it
takes how long because i've seen some of
your tick tocks of like 30 to 60 seconds
i've seen some of your shorts yeah that
could be like 10 seconds long yeah is
that how long it takes you to make the
10 second video it's usually a minimum
two weeks now no
because the one i saw that i really
liked was the tap dancing video
yeah where you were tap dancing with a
mirror and then it comes out and you
watch how you did
that that kind of stunt right that was
two weeks yeah two weeks
and that and those are fun because
they're all on camera is that a lot of
ty i can't tell that's a lot of times so
that's a lot because that was a six
second video oh to me two weeks is is
pretty
fast uh early days like i could knock
them out but they were really simple
like the concepts now are way more
complex um from a production standpoint
so
two weeks is a short amount of time
we've gotten that down like it used to
be
it could have been six months how do you
i'm curious how you make your money back
on that because the one that i saw that
i really liked too was the one you did
with zhc
and you bought the the picture for a
hundred dollars and we should throw up
uh some b-roll of this if we can yeah
and then you went into the picture to
drive the car and it was like the real
thing was behind it right how do you
make money on that because it was such a
short clip it's like where do you
monetize yeah we don't make money on
that we lose money on those um that i
mean they're really
one
i wouldn't do them unless i'm really
excited about making them like as a
filmmaker i love doing what i do so it's
like i'm excited that i get to fund it
but the our business is really leveraged
on the branded side right so like these
pieces are just growing the audience
it's building the audience so that we
could go out to a brand
um
do a production for them and then take
that paycheck and put it back into the
videos again and disperse them across
all the personal content so that's your
main source of income it's just brand
deals yeah that's about 75 because
adsense for us is really low our cpm we
have a huge international audience too
which is awesome but on the the back
side of that is like the cpm kind of
gets washed out a lot so can you share
any of those numbers i mean i know i'll
show you okay i'll show you uh they
can't share it but they're really bad
okay can we see it we're not gonna i'm
not gonna mention what it is you're just
going to get we're going to get our live
reactions
we're going to understand that this is
before your own expenses
um
while you're sharing that would you mind
going over like what what your overhead
is a month for running something like
this
oh i can't i can't share that but okay
it's expensive um
this is the
revenue
you're gonna be shocked because you guys
oh wow
so and these ones
these don't let these skew you because
those are oh yeah those are i know what
it is the youtube yeah okay
wow can i see the uh the views
what do you mean let's go back just the
real time
so most
all right
all right go to the top overview
oh wow now
okay so this is
is this the just the shorts or this is
every oh this is everything that's um
that is the main channel the shorts is a
separate one which i need to show well
you saw it the other day i caught a
glimpse of it yeah at the ping pong
event
wow that's eight points that surprised
million real-time views yeah i think
that's the highest i've ever well aside
from the ping-pong thing yeah most
real-time views i've ever seen
yeah yeah here you go yeah wow so it's
not like we don't make really any money
on adsense it's never been a big
business for us
so we have to do
you know the branded projects which are
awesome because they empower us to like
keep paying off is it just different
model yeah and there are a lot of
youtubers um especially like the kids
and family that have to do it that way
like the cpm is just not great on some
channels that's what i was saying you
guys are skewed on finance right you
guys don't know how good you have it
apparently not that cpm is money see
it's it's interesting because all of our
like all of our friends and like the
people who we talk to they're all in
finance right everybody so we'll compare
adsense numbers with each other right
we're all about on the same par in terms
of like you know per thousand views or
whatever
so yeah that's why i hate social blade
uh oh yeah it's like it's for our
channel totally awesome right but you
know what uh another channel that we
that we compared with was carter sherrar
yeah um
cpm was really good i would say but he
his is uh just really clean
family-friendly yeah but his was like
really decent actually he's making a lot
of money right yeah i think there's some
that it just
does really well
and then i'm not sure i think the reason
why is maybe your your content was a
little bit shorter
because i for him but what does these 10
to 20 minute long videos but it's always
been we've had the channel even when we
were uploading shorts it was always uh
we would do
compilations or whatever and they just
never the cpm i think it's demographics
magic i think it's demographics i mean
yeah who's who's buying magic right
exactly
so right now your main source of income
would you would say sponsorships yeah
okay yeah 75 of our business is through
branded content and where's the other
percentage going um
probably 10 adsense or less uh probably
way less
and then
we also do a lot of productions so stuff
where i won't be in them my team will
produce them uh i might direct them or
or help executive produce but um we are
doing just you won't see me in those so
for example if you watch an amazon ad
right now online
you know we you might even watch it be
like wait that was like was that magic
or was it like a vfx trick
um so we we did those pieces oh okay so
we'll do a lot of just commercial work
that you know as a production company
it's just interesting to hear all of
these i just think of expenses because i
think for us it's like when we talk
about our overhead we don't really have
an office space yeah everything is just
like really what you see here in my
office over there
there's i'm so jealous of that yeah yeah
it's like fit a rotating i would say
realistically probably 98
of what we make is probably just profit
and then whatever we spend on top of
that that's incredible discretionary
yeah it's just do we need something can
we improve something great how can you
improve it's just we don't need to do it
but see i i enjoy the payroll payroll
used to stress me out i was like oh man
like
if uh the business doesn't do well like
there's all these families that are
depending on me but one i took away that
stress knowing that like you know what
if a business fails like people are okay
they can go find they'll it will work
out for them um especially the people i
work with they're really talented they
have other options if that happens so
that got rid of that fear
but the other one is
the
the payroll like i love actually paying
my friends or my team and like working
with them and and being able to
collaborate like i'm
secretly
like or i tell them all the time but
like i love that they're giving me their
a piece of their life like a piece of
their
nine to five time
and sometimes beyond to collaborate on
my stuff so i'm i'm really excited that
i am able to finance that um and i don't
care if it comes from you know
like i'm paying way more than i should
like i could do this solo or not so i
couldn't
i could do this with four or five people
maybe
and try to take more profits but that
would be kind of lame can you say what
percentage of profit you take from the
total gross revenue oh i paid myself a
salary so it's not based on any profit
it's just a flat salary yeah years ago
with my cpa we just set a salary of what
yeah every company does that though you
just with an s course i'm guessing it's
salary and you take
everything else is like a dividend or a
distribution sorry i don't even take
distributions just to set you know
really yeah why not take a distribution
or is is because for me
i don't like i feel like i'm slightly
hurting the business if i were to do
that like i just want to use that money
i'm not as extreme as jimmy where i'm
like everything has to go back into the
content like i want to be able to slowly
pull out some as a salary to save but i
am more on that extreme where it's like
i want to be able to fund these cool
projects yeah and part of it's been
like i don't need a lot of money for
myself to live for my family we live um
very comfortable but we don't need
excessive amounts so for me it's uh
taking enough to invest and then taking
enough to uh
save i'm trying to
purchase a building in la for the
warehouse for the studio space and so
over the years has just been saving for
that project saving for other film
projects longer form stuff um so the
dream is to put it back into like the
longer form stuff that we want to do the
question is why stay in california
talking about getting a building in los
angeles and i know warning signs are
going off in my head i'm like you want
to run a business in los angeles it's
insane what it's insane why
why why do you i knew you're gonna say
that yeah that is probably the worst
place i would say for anything
film-related
and uh i've heard stories from people in
the film industry that are are leaving
because of how restrictive it is for
anything film related during copenhagen
a lot of people flocked away from the
city i don't know i would love to know
how many crew or production people left
um
for me when i did that road trip on in
youtube or years ago
like we went to 30 states and i don't
want to stereotype all the states
um but we we hit up most like the major
cities in them and and went to the
suburban areas and the urban areas
and we just had i mean we saw a lot and
we stayed several days in each place
and we all
i went with two other good friends of
mine best friends we came back we all
said like oh man
southern california is the best spot
like it is so prime geography wise like
weather-wise climate-wise the fact that
we can shoot
every day almost every day of the year
and it's like beautiful out
but you're next to the ocean like
there's so it's just like i love
southern california as a climate
so
that's uh
i and then now now there's like i've
been there for 15 years that's where my
friends are that's where the group is
like how was it moving here like easy
best decision but you had your friends
move out here right like a lot of people
are like well a lot of people were here
already so we didn't move here knowing
nobody if we had i was 80 percent of my
friends let move somewhere
and it was a great tax incentive too
sure i would think about it
but
i don't know traveling like i already do
a lot of traveling i don't want to have
to travel to l.a to go shoot i mean like
we shoot in la all the time that's where
everybody comes yeah why
i was shocked before all the like i shot
now because i thought initially when uh
when i moved to west l.a
and i was like this is awesome because
everyone was around like the same area
so easy and i remember thinking this is
before even considering a move anywhere
else it's like you can't really live
anywhere else because there's an
opportunity cost of leaving and what is
that going to be because everyone's like
i ran into colin and sameer on main
street in santa monica and it was
through just randomly running into them
there that that like a friendship built
from that yep so yeah i'm gonna miss
that
uh but little did i know more people are
excited to come to las vegas i was
shocked yeah because there's more people
here though like you have that for that
yes that's pretty and it's like a short
fight 45 minute flight it's easy and
i've nev like getting people to la was
difficult unless they already live there
right but i'm shocked i'll tell people
like hey we're in vegas be like oh yeah
i'll do a trip there any time and it's
just like they'll make a weekend of it
yeah and they'll just come on the
podcast yeah so i don't know i i think
it would be surprising especially for
filming just the amount of space you
could get
is incredible the tax savings are
incredible they're very business
friendly yeah and i remember even
setting up an s corporation in los
angeles and have i think it was like a
one percent s corp tax that i had to ban
on top of everything else on whatever
was left over in the s corporation yeah
it's like an extra one percent for what
and then i i i hit i got hit with a los
angeles
city tax
that they just assumed i made money on
an
llc that i opened up i didn't do
anything for four years with it nothing
and because i forgot to file an
exemption on that it's my fault but
you're supposed to file an exemption
every single year that it's inactive
yeah even if there's cash sending it
just nothing there was nothing it was
like a hundred bucks in the account i
never used it um i just forgot but they
sent me a tax bill for like 17 grand oh
because for those four years they're
like well because you didn't do anything
we're assuming you're gonna make two
hundred thousand dollars a year i'm like
200 grand a year for what but they taxed
me based on that it was a mess to try to
unravel all that but that was los
angeles and i had to file that for every
single llc yeah they opened up
everything it was just horrible yep so
yeah i was i was surprised to get out
and just now that i was out after a few
months i can't even think about going
back i i don't mind going back for a
weekend and i find it really cool to
like get out um but no i couldn't it
would take a uh
joe rogan level deal for me to move that
makes sense yeah
but
uh
i did look at some warehouse space in l
in vegas though or just online
okay graham's gonna ask me about this
what do we have here um yeah your prices
are definitely enticing i mean it's not
it's actually not i was was surprised
like it's it's expensive yeah because
everyone from california is working
there yeah warehouse space is like
slightly cheaper here but uh yeah i
would say it's probably 30 cheaper but i
don't know the spaces i was looking at
like here's the thing
warehouse and distribution space which
is kind of what i'm looking for
hasn't dropped a lot at all like it's
only going up because everybody needs
that
so yeah
it's it's uh it's yeah i'm okay i'm okay
paying taxes
to have what we have in la though like
it's
the vibes are great and not even lac
like not all of la's awesome to me but
just
uh
nowhere else can you be like
five minutes from the beach
also in the mountains
also near one of the biggest production
cities in the world still i know a lot
of people left but you know when we do
our shoots and productions it's hard to
know right like are they really coming
there and i'm part of them because we're
there or would that be the same amount
of work in vegas i don't know i think
you're right though having vague like
the strip right there and just vegas
being what it is and everyone knows it
for
sure you're gonna probably entice it's
like oh yeah you could do that too
andrew graham's thing that makes sense
yes
yeah it's just easy yeah i think it
would be fun to discuss why you're here
today and how we met because what
happened yesterday was it two days ago
uh yes i have a question for you guys so
yeah um two days ago
i won 120 000
on a table tennis
a table tennis tournament
which is uh i looked up i was asking
some of the olympians there i was like
wait how much is a regular like table
tennis prize purse yeah and they were
like
maybe 60 70 000.
like the high-end ones and i was like no
you're telling me this is like the most
of course it'd be a youtuber that maybe
you know
um
but okay what do i do with 120 000
not what do i do but so what i wanted
how do i invest it to grow it and then i
want to go back with eric and like do
some sort of giveaway
uh eventually or like figure out some i
wanted one take time to figure out what
to do that's clever
um but investment wise what do i do with
the money in the money
where are you investing right now like
what's what's your portfolio kind of
look like
i'm like 70
real estate okay 20 stocks
10
cash reserves waiting to buy no crypto
uh well in sorry my stocks yes there's
crypto in there right so of the 70 real
estate how much of that is rental versus
business versus primary uh almost all of
its rental oh good what about your
primary do you own my personal yeah uh
i have a mortgage on it yeah okay
and of the stocks that index funds or
it's uh 75 it's
70 stocks
15
etf
15 crypto i think i did the math on that
wrong but it's uh i know 15 on crypto is
correct 15 on etf is correct so overall
then if it's so it's i'm trying to
calculate what's your crypto total in
relation to everything else like what
percentage it's gonna be like two points
yeah two percent yeah not even yeah
maybe like one eight i would i would i
think it would be fun to put it in
crypto oh crypto that's what i'm leaning
towards i
yeah because i think that if you have a
long enough time horizon let's say 15 to
20 years i i don't know if anything's
gonna happen in the short term and
that's why i say like 10 15 years
probably 10 years let's just see that i
i think it's going to do well but it's
also small enough in relation to
everything else where if it goes to zero
it's not going to be the end of the
world right anyway
i don't know to me i probably do 60
bitcoin 60 ethereum
it's just a one-time thing and
forget about it just forget about it
stake it somewhere but didn't you say
you wanted to do something with iraq
with the 120 grand i do yeah
then put it in crypto like i don't even
know but you could always wait on your
time
the chance of it going to zero i mean
like i don't think it's gonna go to zero
i think you're you're worthless you
realize it but i also think i also don't
think i would just do it all in one
thing like i think i would take my time
and do
it doesn't have to come from that it
could be if you would like 120 yeah
120 from someone else mccash you're just
asking how he would invest 120 yeah but
not necessarily the 120 grand he got
married yeah i mean if you're doing it
for them well i mean mentally yes that's
where from where it's you know from in
that moment but yeah it's gonna be so
let's just say you have 120 grand
on something else giving it back not
that you got to win fun no no it's just
having 100 i would have fun with that
okay quick go crypto
even but it depends on play like safe
you want to play i think you have enough
to fall back on where it doesn't matter
and you could you could make a riskier
allocation with it with a small so are
you in crypto yeah how much how much how
much
uh
nearly 10. okay
so
would you have recommendations for what
which crypto i have okay so i give you
some money
drops you 120 right now yeah what do you
put it in
if i were to do cryptos i would probably
do
i would probably do
45 bitcoin 40 45 ethereum and then 10
just like maybe something altcoins
which altcoins i don't know
he hasn't found them yet yeah
elon balls yeah
i'm not sure uh maybe uh maybe
uh solana oh yeah yeah martian solana i
do yeah
i'm excited about that one yeah
cardona maybe
yeah it would be interesting just some
random stuff that could pop off probably
yeah i don't think you could go wrong
with that and maybe you could maybe we
could look back at this but i don't know
that's not financial advice you guys
right but no
but it's interesting i don't think you
can go wrong with it
you'll definitely not lose money on that
but no but it's interesting at least for
me with bitcoin ethereum the more
research i do the more excited i get
about it yeah and i've never had that
with any other investment where like
usually the more you research you reach
a point where like all right i think i
understand it enough i'm not exactly
sure anything can happen but it's i see
such a big potential and what's really
interesting to me is that uh the more i
see that millennials and gen z are
choosing crypto over stocks and there's
like this mental shift of like oh stocks
are for boomers and old people and i'm
not going to be a part of that uh and
what's up what's on is that a lot of
millennials feel like the stock market
is is more corrupt and more manipulated
than cryptocurrency is even though i
think right now cryptocurrency is way
easier uh way more easily manipulative
there's like i buy like probably tenfold
i don't know what you guys view on this
but like i feel like youtubers are
moving some of these coins
certainly certainly they can just like
pump and dump stuff it depends on the
cryptocurrency the market cap the
context and if they are actually behind
it um
i i think if anything probably twitter
has just as large of an impact because
it seems like a lot of this tends to
start on twitter or usually what
actually what what what i've seen behind
the scenes that it seems to like the
discord groups which then i'll talk
about it and then it goes to twitter and
it'll go from twitter to youtube and
then
like then the big mainstream outlets
start to pick up on it like the cnbc's
and the cnns and the market watches and
they'll do things on but i don't know
but i think there's a new type of
investing right now that's based on
momentum community and attention and and
it's you can't you can't value that yeah
like gamestop was a perfect example of
that where it's like the the community
came together all really like the stock
and it's still trading at like over 200
yeah gamestop crazy doesn't make any
sense and a year and a half ago
not even was it a year no yeah a year
and a half goes like six dollars a share
not that i mean not i don't say not that
much happened but it's from five dollars
two 200 yeah a year and a half but it's
the community that's so strong behind it
and uh sam i think also plays with tesla
is that it's such like this um
this cult like following for elon musk
is it worth anyone i don't know but the
community and the momentum says it is
yeah and so how long could that continue
and what what price do you value that on
so i think with a lot of these coins um
you know long term who knows what's
going to happen but
with uh dogecoin it's like it's stupid
coin it's it's a me literally i mean
it's stupid i'm still holding myself
careful watch your mouth
yeah i should uh i should educate myself
but
it's a silly coin i mean it's silly it's
silly nobody could buy into do it and
say it's not it's a silly coin they
started it off as a joke but now it's
got a market gap of 30 billion dollars i
think it would be fun to discuss some of
the content creation process because
for some reason you have some ability to
just go viral on every single like form
of social media ever and i don't
understand it because you've also gone
mainstream uh you were on uh ellen
degeneres and you're on like you said
the amazing race you've been in a movie
i saw that zootopia is in my crib my
imdb i don't know how to do my imdb but
uh zootopia is listed you're on zootopia
because i have one voice cameo yeah yeah
which they gave me gosh uh when the
first time you go in the police scene
you can hear me saying like
he bore his teeth first it wasn't me
that's but um yeah you've done
everything well tv shows too
here's my thing uh i go to a lot of
different conferences and speak at them
and also attend where
uh youtubers they always try to break
down which is fine the algorithm and
figure out like what is the best seo you
know year your couple you remember a
couple years ago was like
really it was thumbnails right like red
circles like figure out what the you
know kind of jake paul days everyone's
like okay thumbnails is the new thing
and then
um but instead of reverse engineering
the the algorithm which i think is
important the one metric today i think
creators should be watching is retention
because um
that will drive up the suggested
viewers
but for me it's always i mean
i'm looking at from the long tail of
like doing this for 12 years i think
it's about the only thing is the stories
and the content and the characters in
your videos
and you know building that relationship
with your audience
it doesn't matter what platform you're
on i think youtube's a really really
strong one like i would bank most if it
was a you know it is a stock but if it
was a tradable platform just if you had
platforms uh i would put most of my
money on youtube being the front runner
still for a long time
because you can build a whole ancillary
you know a bunch of businesses around it
but that doesn't mean you don't need
other ones to help build your brand i
think instagram and tick tock especially
tick tock lately it's been great what i
noticed is
um youtube you have a core audience
right they just come back they watch
your videos and if you keep making great
stuff they'll continue to come back and
it'll kind of grow over time slowly
but you need the tick tocks and the
instagrams are that you don't need them
but they're really helpful for branding
and sometimes mainstream like with tick
tick-tock we've found like more people
come up to me now
versus like a lot of people still came
up to me on youtube but way more come up
based on tick tock and you could just
see the in throughout the years like
when it was vine people coming up or
when it was instagram blew up you know
or when it was snapchat even you could
see these waves and you could tell
because when people are taking selfies
you can see what what apps they're on
and how they're doing it and it was
pretty obvious where they come from or
they'll just say like oh i saw this tick
tock you know or they call you that so
my title has changed so many times over
the last 12 years it was you know um at
one point it was like you're a musically
star
i know you from musically you know um
but like
those platforms are all helpful for
kind of breaking into the mainstream
it's weird though like
i i wonder when we're gonna stop using
the word mainstream because youtube is
mainstream like like why are we still
calling it i don't know youtube creators
that's fine but like eventually it's
just like oh i watch this person right
right you know like i feel like i watch
if you're talking about dave ramsey like
you watch him on youtube yeah like he's
a youtuber
uh not in the traditional sense but it's
like we're all watching on the same
place at this point
that's interesting that you've paid
attention to the i don't see the back
end but like the metrics of the video
itself because for us it's always title
thumbnail that we could have the most
amazing video in the world and if we
don't have the right title and thumbnail
nobody watches it yeah and i've had it
so many times where i've posted a video
and it's been
a 10 out of 10 which means it's like the
worst video we've posted out of the last
10. okay and the video itself is awesome
and all we do is change the title and
the thumbnail to something a little more
when do you do that in the first hour oh
if what if you don't do in the first
hour uh it has less of an effect okay
i've noticed at least in the first hour
youtube is recommending the video enough
to get immediate feedback on the video
so when you post are you just waiting
like kind of watching yeah and in the
first hour you're ready to pivot or do
you already have other thumbnails ready
so uh so the way it works is that we
post and usually i don't look at any of
the metrics for the first 15 minutes
okay sometimes it's like things could
happen in the first five or ten yeah uh
usually though after about 10 minutes
you could kind of tell but 15 minutes in
we look at what the initial
click-through rate was of the title so
we could see on the on the analytics if
you get a big spike the first minute
past a certain like number like for us
it's past 1500
uh anything above 1500 we know the title
is correct because enough people clicked
on uh in the first minute then we see
what is the momentum like those next 15
minutes is the graph going up is it
going down and how does that do to in
relation to every other video we've
posted yeah and at this point we have a
backlog of probably two to three hundred
videos mentally in our minds that we
could compare it to we're like this is
our usual this is good this is bad these
topics do good and these topics do
poorly sometimes we'll post a video and
we'll know it's gonna be like a nine
yeah which means it's not the worst but
it's pretty bad and are those ones ones
like we have a lot in our library that
randomly
sometimes years later just blow up out
of nowhere do you guys have that
not really no the videos that that do
well long term are long tail videos so
like we'll say how to invest in the
stock market for beginners i don't know
100 i'll post that video it'll do
terribly it'll be my worst performing
video in the first like two months but
those videos get such consistent views
that within about six months
it'll be one of the top performing
videos uh so you can't do that all the
time but those videos are great as like
uh
those are kind of like you're building
out a spider web to collect like new
subscribers and viewers and that'll just
consistently get like new flies in there
yeah just made that up but those videos
are really well um just those provide
the foundation because they always get
views yeah so if you could get a hundred
of those in the pipeline every day each
of those will make you know a few bucks
yeah so that's like that's your
foundation then everything else is you
know just entertainment see we yeah we
don't even
i don't even know what my title
click-through rate is
because for us like i'm not trying to
seo so for example a video that's
incredibly i think it's got 100 million
views on our
youtube channel it's called furniture
illusions the most random topic of all
things right like
not many people are looking up illusions
in the first i mean there's a lot but
relative to other things um and then
furniture like that's a pretty low
search thing
but
that randomly
takes off not you know the first week
not even the first two weeks it was like
months later and a lot of our videos do
that it seems to be
it somehow goes into the algorithm at
some point
and it says like oh and this is where i
think retention is really important um
it knows that it's getting a higher
watch time and but it's weird that our
videos like could be months later yeah
so for us the content creation isn't
about like title or thumbnail it really
is like the step above that which is
what is this video is about what like
what's interesting about this yeah i
think every channel has a slightly
different algorithm it seems like maybe
and mine is going to be different than
yours yeah because i've seen some other
channels too uh it was interesting we
were talking to the strad man a while
ago and each of his videos consistently
will hit between 1 and 1.2 million views
no matter what he does he could post a
bad video a million views a great video
1.2 million views it's always within
that range no matter what he does and
it's interesting that like that's his
baseline like youtube sets that is his
recommendations regardless of how much
his subscribers grow yeah it's like
that's his that's his thing and for us
we have a certain range that like almost
no matter what video we post as long as
it's you know on par it's gonna do you
know a certain amount of views what
about on the ice is the iced coffee hour
different like have you seen different
metrics you guys do the same thing like
you look at something very similar a few
videos end up getting recommended uh we
had one with jeanette mccurdy it did
really well and at first it it was a
good video at first but i think it just
it hit her audience or it was the same
time that what was it like the icarly
thing came out yeah we had her honestly
that was just the reboot yeah okay so we
had her on and posted
by coincidence at the same time that
yeah bunch of search terms yes and then
i think youtube saw that that video was
being searched people were watching it
and started recommending to that
audience yeah so every now and then we
hit the things it also happened with the
king pokemon thing like i remember we we
released king pokemon we released an
episode with him and immediately it was
like a 10 out of 10 or nine hours so bad
like really really important
and then it was like i think it was
about six days after he posted i
remember i was at a spike ball
tournament and all of a sudden there was
a huge bump in the views and graham
texted me like dude look what's
happening and i looked what was it uh
like after like when i was a news thing
that happened no no it was just it hit
the audience that likes the pokemon
content like his fan base and everything
and we didn't change title we didn't
change thumbnail literally and all of a
sudden every single day just got more
and more and more views and then it was
a one out of ten by far yeah yeah we
have certain videos where i feel like
youtube is really
youtube wants the video to succeed yeah
and i really believe that they're trying
to find they're trying scrambling to a b
test different audiences and if it could
test and then this is successful in a
test that's exact it finds like the
right person for the video and then it's
like if this person liked this video
we're going to recommend it to other
people who also we got them yeah exactly
lock it in so like a good example two
was i did a video with michael reeves
and i was so excited for this video and
i thought for sure this would be like a
knockout video
it was at the time by far i mean it was
half it did half the views of the next
worst performing video hat yeah it's
like ah crap i guess this isn't going to
work anymore yep and then i think it was
like three days later same thing as boom
and it hit michael reeves audience and
started recommending to people who watch
michael reeves yep and so so it's just
it's interesting another video that's
the video where uh yeah i watched that
one he talks about simon proper you're
like what are you invested he's like
simon properties yeah yeah
but look at that that did well it did
every time i see that stock i think of
him because of that it i hope he's still
in that i thought it was tesla too
wasn't it tesla no it was literally he
said he was only simon's property yeah
he was like all he had
was kind of a random one he didn't even
know about
yeah was he in it for the dividends or
something
i think it was didn't he say his friend
told him or something yeah yeah and he
just went all in
so that's funny it worked they're doing
well i like simon property yeah
yeah i i got it because of that actually
so across all of your different like
social media platforms uh do you is your
goal to like redirect everything to
youtube
and us it's not an intentional goal but
i do like that because that's where we
grow the real community like the people
who really care about
our work and even it attracts more of a
filmmaker
to the channel like that's
kind of my vibe and my mo so
ideally that's where people go and it's
just longer for i really think sitting
down with your favorite creator and
spending six minutes in a video is way
way more powerful than having you know
60 million people watch it for like 15
seconds even if it
doesn't
i don't know they're swiping onto the
next thing right most of their platform
well they don't even like individually
select to watch your content on tick
tock it just gets recommended if they're
just going through their feed which is
how everyone searches but on youtube if
you're gonna click on like like
someone's channel or a recommendation or
something like that you actually have to
actively click on it yeah so i feel like
that also can establish a different
relationship with the viewer as well but
have you also noticed that there is
there are different viewers on each
platform like your fans are different on
this platform or is it kind of like
crosshatch no it's interesting like they
don't like a lot of people i mean make
sense because we our most our followers
are on instagram or tiktok or
other platforms
not many people know we have youtube
channel like they're usually pretty
shocked and like what i'm always like
wait you seem like a pretty
in-depth fan but you don't know we have
a youtube channel it's just a lot of
people are either i think this
is depends on
how you use social media like my wife is
only on instagram she doesn't really
watch many youtubers she kind of just
knows again like the people she follows
do minutes of stories or like they could
do eight minutes of stories a day right
so she's kind of watching a version of
it and chopped up
um so it's just
it's different i think uh
based on how you it's it's really weird
to me though even in vegas like meeting
people on the strip they're like dude i
am the biggest fan of your tick tock
videos and i was like oh my did you
watch our youtube videos and they're
like what oh my youtube channel like
what's different there and that i think
that's the thing though you have to
if you have if you're drawing people to
it it has to be really different so for
us it's like we're still
really only a year into redeveloping the
youtube channel like
for many years it's just we have like 10
or 12 million subscribers on youtube
yeah but most of them are because we ran
them we didn't know he had a channel for
a long time we were uploading the shorts
uh not as short not youtube shorts but
like the short little clips yeah and
we're just putting on i was just
uploading them when i'd make a new one
same as i put them on instagram and tick
tock and then we looked one day and like
holy crap this channel is like
actually growing we need to make
long-form content which is one reason i
think the cpm isn't good because yeah
we've kind of just started figuring out
in the last year and a half like we need
to do longer form like if you do look at
the library of
from years ago it's all like 20 seconds
and the watch time is just like it's
been pulled down because i'm thinking
about like maybe i need to go through
and
youtube says it's not uh worth doing or
doesn't affect it but i feel like it
does like i need to go totally delete no
no no no no no no no don't delete videos
that's the worst why is that bad oh my
god we heard from todd bupro himself
that deleting videos is bad okay who did
we hear from i heard it from today pro i
asked him uh in clubhouse back in the
olden days when we used to use that and
he said basically like a month ago yeah
no this is like six months ago but the
algorithm yeah todd b pro who's like the
head of the algorithm at youtube you
know okay uh he said that once you
delete a youtube video like
youtube collects mess up the web or
something yeah kind of youtube collects
data based off of the viewer it's not
based off of the video and basically if
you delete a video
youtube will treat
each viewer that saw that video as if
they had never seen that video or
interacted with that video so if you
were your channel so no just just that
video which obviously is tied to your
channel yeah so like let's say like you
have like 10 viewers that went and
watched this one video of yours and they
liked it or something then youtube's
going to be like oh these 10 viewers
they're going to probably want to see
other content similar to this and
they're going to recommend other of your
videos to this to these people right but
if you delete that one video that's the
ch that is the vessel between like you
and the viewers so it's a pool literally
just it basically treats it as it as
though they had never seen that video or
they've never interacted so by deleting
let's say i mean i might have a lot i
have to look but like
it could be like two or three hundred
watch now you'll stream
this yeah i'll leave it we i we've
tested this so many times on our channel
that we never delete videos anymore i
remember this so i ended up doing it was
what about listening no
no we literally go into the youtube
i'll i'll get to that so so here's what
happened on my main channel tips i was
four months into doing youtube videos
and my channel started getting
recommended and i ended up taking down
two of those videos because they were
videos that i just
like back when i was embarrassed by him
no i was i swore i swore in those videos
i really tried to clean up some of the i
just made like stupid jokes in the video
not not nothing inappropriate well
i would say it's like it's not going to
hurt it's not going to count it was
inappropriate yeah it's not cancelable
but if people are now googling they're
leaving they're inappropriate
toilet humor that a like a teenage boy
would joke about that's all it is yeah
it's like when you think it's just like
okay so it's immature adult swim sort of
humor that i was making in videos
talking about how to make passive income
that was it i mean it's innocent enough
but when i but when those videos i never
thought anybody would watch the videos
yeah then when people watch the videos
and i and i was still i was full time as
a real estate agent i didn't want those
videos coming back and clients thinking
i was not professional sure talking
about like making these stupid jokes oh
so you were working i mean you were a
real estate agent at the time oh yeah
full-time real estate agent like i
wasn't making money from youtube like
that was just a side for fun so you
haven't sworn on the channel since then
no so so basically so i took down those
videos because i was like i don't want
clients to see this i want a
professional image still so i'm going to
take down those videos and not swear
anymore yep as soon as i took down those
videos there's like two of them my
channel just like 80 drop off huh like
almost immediately and it took me months
took me like eight months to build back
up where you just you swear from that
and it was from that it was
instantaneously it took down those
videos
eight months to build back up the same
momentum eight months and then there was
another time where i deleted the video
the same thing happened um
yeah it was it was another it was
another video i think i just took it
down uh same thing happened the
algorithm went down took a few months to
get back but the real test was on the
second channel we had a guy call in um i
guess we could talk about it it's been
long enough i won't reveal anything but
we had a guy call in who owned a
franchise and he was telling us all the
details about this franchise like how
much he was making for the franchise how
you could own a franchise like the inner
workings which was really interesting
because it was this whole culture and
nothing bad it was just like public
information oh yeah kind of no it was he
said it was public information okay well
anyways the board that goes he revealed
too much information for him
and the board saw the video which i
don't know how they saw the video it
must have gotten recommended or someone
sent it to him or something like that it
was a great video and it was one of our
most successful videos on the second
channel
and he called and was like hey i'm
really sorry i don't want to do this but
like i'm
this is going to impact my ability to
open up another franchise unless this
video comes down like all right we're
going to take the video down so we took
it down and instantly the whole channel
how many months did it yeah it was
probably like it was probably like four
months wow okay so i'm not deleting
anything don't do it yeah so what we do
instead what we found a good workaround
so we had another person call in on the
second channel and uh
she said some things that she later
regretted saying and so she asked us
trim them out uh yes so well the entire
premise of the video was all centered
around something that she did not want
but she later regretted it
people just need to sign a paper that
says like i know they're gonna say
things i don't regret yeah but basically
what we did was we went to the youtube
editor and made the entire video just an
intro yes so it's literally what's up
you guys it's graham here and welcome
back to the second channel with that
said you guys thank you so much for
watching everything you literally
chopped out yes
we changed the title thumbnail so it's
unsearchable yeah and i think the title
or something like that it's literally so
like oh he accidentally uploaded this
yeah yeah but that means all the data is
retained in that video yeah oh and then
we hid comments yeah people wouldn't be
able to everything because the comments
revealed what the video is about yeah
right so it worked and we didn't know
like you know there was also another how
is the youtube uh trimmer
oh it's it's it's challenging it's it's
very confusing get it down
to the frame right you're just not like
no
yeah but there's another video too we
did a house tour and uh the lady was all
fine with us using it i'm not gonna ask
you to delete the video and then
apparently the person who was buying the
house was a high profile person they
wanted the video down right and she's
like you gotta take the video down i
i've refused because this video took a
long time to make and it was going to
throw off the algorithm the channel was
on off swing so i said how about this
we'll keep the video up but i'll change
the title and thumbnail to make it
unsearchable she's like
that's fine as long as nobody can see it
i'm like nobody's gonna find so i hid
this video basically it doesn't show up
in search anymore you have to scroll
back like two years to find that you
know nobody's gonna find it yeah but
anyway it's uh very interesting okay
those are the tricks yeah just but in
short don't delete any of the videos
yeah
yeah but there's no point if unless
unless there's something on there that
you don't want up there anymore there's
no point in changing title and stuff
like that unless you have to delete a
video in which case just edit it out
yeah
that's a good tip to know yeah
try that so we've learned everything
just through trial and error seeing what
works and we're just like anything with
the algorithm we watch it
everything yeah
so does it affect
your content though at the end of the
day do you go back to the does it affect
writing the next one um yes and no but
i'm i'm vigilant on how
user interaction is going to go
throughout the video and i'm really
cognizant of like are people going to
continue watching so like every
minute and a half there's a hook yeah
and i change the scenes on purpose
because i notice if i'm just at a desk
talking it's boring so every two minutes
or so what's your guys's retention do
you know
50 to 60 oh that's pretty that's really
good so it's average view time is seven
to eight minutes this the family is like
we can get up to like 75 percent on this
to family but the second channel in the
main channel is 50 to 60 percent yeah
wow it's high so for finance but that's
because i liked i i all so what i do is
i'll script out the video and then i
read it back to myself and if there's
any point where i'm reading where it
doesn't make sense or i i lose my own
focus
i'll either cut it out or i'll put a
hook in there yeah or a question i think
that's important as long as the going to
the analytics and the data is changing
positively oh yeah the content then
that's great well at the end of the day
it's just about keeping retention and
entertainment at the same time so if
someone's not entertained there's no
point in watching my video yeah so i
would say it's like that mix i mean for
you guys it's probably entertainment but
it's also highly on value right like if
you're not providing value and you're
just entertaining like unless that's why
we're going to watch the channel then
you're missing the mark it has to be it
has to be a mix of both yeah
so that's awesome so zack king if you
could rank the least important to the
most important form of social media to
have a presence on how would you rank it
if you don't have a presence on youtube
you won't be able to survive
for the long tale of it if that if
social media you're trying to make that
your career
like being a content creator you have to
have youtube
um but it doesn't mean the other ones
are important
it just means
i think if i were to rebuild a channel i
would do it from youtube as a base and
use the others to build it up
but you know i wouldn't have a tick tock
channel alone when i have an instagram
alone um that just doesn't make sense
anymore so they all need each other but
you would say youtube is the most
important but then what would it go
would it go like as most important
youtube and then tick tock than
instagram oh yeah snapchat the order
right now is and again it changes on the
climate like it feels like
it was moving a lot faster it's kind of
slowed down i feel like we're in a weird
plateau of like no new platforms uh in a
long time no new innovation on social
media so yeah youtube is your base
absolutely have to be on tick tock
are you you're on tick tock are you guys
on tick tock yeah we have iced coffee
hour clips on tick tock it's got like 90
thousand followers
today are you really yeah did you right
here right here i want to ask you a
question from preferred tick-tock well i
wanted to film a tick tock with zach
well it's too late great you could vote
first no no no jack can't do it okay i
called it first well wait i wanted to
film it
all right fine alex gets a tick tock
all right so you got you got youtube
then you got tick-tock but it depends
who you are like i've seen i follow a
lot of podcasters and it's like twitter
is some of their that's the way i find
out there's a new podcast
um it really depends like a news
journalist i'm gonna follow him on
twitter you know i'm not gonna follow
him on uh instagram yeah so it really
depends what you do i've seen the
biggest engagement from instagram
because for me like youtube is is is
good but then my instagram is the
concentration of the people who really
care about the youtube channel and
myself will follow me on instagram yep
so anytime i do it well it used to be
the swipe ops but when i used to do the
swipe ops i'd have such a high
click-through rate that like it would
eclipse youtube by like 10 times so it
depends how you build it like me i'm
stuck at where i built my instagram as a
so i built every platform as a solo
thing it didn't have a purpose so like
you started as youtube and you probably
i'm guessing said
if you want to know more about me and
you're really into my stuff go follow
instagram correct so those instagramers
you're able just to always say swipe up
or go see this new video here for me i
built it just on instagram and they came
for the short stuff and so now if i do
anything else they're like dude
why am i why are you sending me to
youtube because
this is where i started following you
and this is what i wanted all right so
if if if you don't
you it's hard to pivot later on those
platforms like what you use it for
what questions do you have for us okay i
want to know about your process i want
to know about
when i hear your uh recently it was uh
uh
you had a jimmy's manager on
and uh super smart guy
you guys it sounds like there's
bandwidth issues like you're i was like
i'm so busy so so br you're almost
burning out i don't know if you're
burning out but i'm like
from my perspective it seems like if you
had
a writer
and if you had an editor i know you have
alex he's awesome yeah so alex michael
january 1st i want alex to take over the
videos on the the main channel so he
would edit them so like my goal in a
perfect world is like after this i'm
going to be filming i'm going to film
that video i'm going to be done let's
say 8 p.m i would love for him to edit
at night yep and then that way the next
morning we could review the video
together and have it done so i could
plan out the next video alex
you ready for the night shift
i've actually been
working my regular job and the night
shift for the past couple of weeks you
have another job no this is business i
mean the night shift is in like editing
okay so yeah
how many years have you been doing this
five five years
wow you've been what's your schedule
like how many hours you work a week uh
usually i try to take weekends like half
days yeah but i would say monday through
fridays definitely seven a.m to seven
p.m usually okay this monday through
friday saturday is usually a half day so
it could be i like working morning so i
i love going from like 7 a.m to 12 yeah
on a saturday or 7 to 3 or whatever and
then sunday would be maybe another half
day or a full day so i would say within
a week i definitely get at least one
full day off
usually the weekends are both half you
know what it is graham you need to have
a kid no once you have no no no no no no
don't even no no no no no no no
priorities just seem to change uh and
you realize like all the little things
you do half of them somebody else can do
and it just forces you to i don't wanna
i don't wanna i don't have to have a kid
just to just to change up my schedule i
love listen i love my schedule i really
value the freedom yeah of being able to
work this many hours yeah so i'm
absolutely not in a rush to so what
would you okay if you had more time what
would you do with it uh
it sounds great it would work more yeah
you'd work more but like what would the
output look like is it like a goal are
you trying to like ramp up to like
four or five videos no i don't really
want to ramp up i i want to just
continue i don't know if if i had more
time honestly i'd probably go to the gym
a little bit more yeah um
you'd be happier yeah yeah honestly i'd
probably be a little bit happier okay i
would be a little less stressed this is
important to you you mentioned that
earlier that will translate into the
content yes yeah yeah yeah true um i'd
probably go to the gym more uh be a
little happier and spend more time uh
both with macy and with the aquarium
the i love the aquarium as you had seen
right when you walked in like that is my
first thing
joy i'd spend more time tinkering on
that yeah tank
that's great so that's yeah so but part
of me would see that is like oh this
this means i could work more so yeah i
could do a better job now yeah i would i
would just ask what in your process
is your least favorite part
see it's weird for me because i like
editing for me it's like it's it's a
therapeutic yeah because i i know i
could look at the time be like i just
zone out yeah and it becomes like this
thing where i can do it with my eyes
closed and just
the time stops and i look down and be
like oh the video's done yeah four hours
went by great and i'm really happy with
like the way it turned out it's perfect
yeah i would say the hardest part for me
is planning and thinking of a good topic
because it's hard to because once you
commit to a topic there's 10 hours right
there yeah between planning and filming
what's your involvement in the main
channel
nothing really oh no he just runs by
title thumbnails by me sometimes video
ideas sometimes i watch the videos and
give them my opinion on editing and
stuff like that
yeah cool
well
it sounds like one role that'd be
interesting as a like a producer like a
and you could start it super low so it's
not like coming with that title and you
feel like you're
having to listen to every suggestion
they give but maybe it's training
another person to bounce those ideas off
or or ideas believe it or not we got we
got to should we tell them about the dgb
mention
okay
i don't know if we're gonna include this
okay okay i don't know if we're gonna
include this
uh we have a subscriber
he's watching this right now what's up
it's awesome
dedicated loyal but it's awkward to talk
about okay so yes so dgb has commented
first on every single one of my videos
for probably what a year and a half or
two years
almost he usually almost like 90 he's
the first comment across all the videos
and it got to a point where this was
like what five months ago
he started to
calculate the rankings of the video
within the first five minutes of posting
and i post a video and within five
minutes you'd be like i could tell this
is going to be a 6. i could tell this is
going to be a 4. yep this video is not
doing that well it's probably the title
and we noticed month after month he was
correct yes before we and we were we had
all the analytics
he didn't have access he was literally
just going off the video itself
and so there was a point where he was
right so many times
and uh he said that like this video i
could tell is a seven
and i said but wait a second but but the
the views are lagging on your side right
how could you tell because we see the
real time you're seeing what youtube is
showing you he's a i don't even look at
the views anymore you could tell how
well it's doing based on the like ratio
of the video i was like what do you mean
the like ratio he's like well if you
take your likes in the first five
minutes and you multiply that by 10
that's how many views you're getting and
so based on the first five minutes i
created this this spreadsheet of all of
your past videos and i could rank now
based on the likes of the video how well
it's doing yeah i was blown away it
turns out he's 15 years old at his age
he is more skilled than i would say that
than i am at this
than jack is at this or alex or any of
us with fewer pieces of data at his
disposal and he was so good at that and
he and he watches all the videos and all
of our videos by the way between me and
jeremy kevin and andre like he knows
everything and he has for years that i
now trust him to pass by video topics
and and titles and thumbnails by him
first yeah and he gives better title and
thumbnail ideas than i than i even have
because he's so in it more than more
than i am which i didn't think was
possible i really think it is if you can
find the right fit and it's a fan that
wants to work with you
that will that's like the you know
employees there usually is a time in
their period of employment with you that
they just need that fire and that
passion uh excitement from what you do
to carry them through those like lulls
of like oh i don't want to do this work
or this is the difficult part uh and
that's like when a fan is in that role
that's what carries yeah what's even
what's even crazier is that he noticed
based on the subtleties
that the editing was different that it
was alex
and and i went through alex's videos to
make it as close to mine as possible he
noticed like the little subtle changes
in editing yeah it's like
is that alex yep yep so it's very cool
yeah i would try to find ways to
outsource
again like you want to do it in a way
like a producer is a great role for it
if it can encompass maybe that title
means for you
they do some of the writing they do a
lot of the research or topics and
they're well versed in that and then
they help you just do the logistics of
like maybe it's coordinating a guest
other things that might not seem like
they take time but actually kind of do
alex we're going to call you a producer
now how's that
uh
come with me but i i i hey
let's not all right
i get nervous of the night shift stuff
so why we used to do it a good amount
um because of the same reason hey we
want to see this at in the morning and
we would have us people do it but that
doesn't last super long like they're
physically there's only like a certain
amount of time like my mom's a nurse and
she used to do a night shift for many
years and it just literally can see it
physically change your body over time so
just let your gun at some point that
person's probably going to say no or
just mentally not be able to it would be
alex so alex what do you think of that
that's a great question i mean there was
one day i came in here just because the
edit went longer than i expected
graham and i reviewed and then i went
home and i was like grandma i need to go
get some sleep
um
so i don't think that editing videos on
the night shift is sustainable forever
however i do think that it's necessary
especially with a quick turnaround time
so i think as long as it's not the
op you know the route that you go every
night but let's say
you know 10 25 of the time that's what
needs to happen long term i think that
would be yeah it's it's tough because
there there are some times where it's
tuesday night and i finish filming at 8
p.m and that video needs to post the
next day at
3 30 without fail it has to post and we
have to have enough time i would just
make it i don't think the night shifting
so i think the issue is that he has a
day job plus he's doing a night well no
no no well this this would this would
turn into this would turn into just that
yeah so he could sleep until 12 he wants
to as long as the video's done yeah this
would be uh after
training after training
he's in the uh the training phase right
now yeah the hazing the goal is that
either you ideally not you but alex then
trains two more people to do it that
maybe not full time i don't want to
scare you on payroll stuff but they
could be freelancers they could be
uh maybe part time that you know you
have x person from monday to wednesday
if video gets shot during that time it
needs to be the night shift or whatever
you want to do and then another person
for wednesday through friday or through
the weekend or whenever um that you just
booked their time and you know yeah this
is my schedule because you know your
schedule right when you're sometimes
when you're shooting though when i'm by
the time i'm filming but sometimes that
could be last minute okay yeah so
yeah
we do all our shoots on a wednesday and
friday pretty much without fail i know
it doesn't work like that yeah and so
but if there is a rhythm why is it
because it's new it's yeah yeah i would
say probably 80 75 of the content is on
current events yeah where if i miss it
by 24 hours it's relevant anymore that's
why it's so hard i can't compete with
meet kevin
and there are some some videos that i
know he'll get out a video within 30
minutes he's faster than cnbc now right
uh because as soon as he sees something
he has better thoughts because he knows
the market that he could explain
everything yeah 30 minutes and usually
after that if kevin does a better job
than i would be able to do on a video i
won't even make it anymore because i'm
like what's the point kevin just did a
better job if i can at least the feeling
where you get depressed you're just like
why am i even doing this yeah well the
thing is i know if if i can't at least
keep up to that caliber or do better i'm
not gonna do it if someone else has
already done it see i actually disagree
with that though really yes because
you're followers
i don't think it's like
i follow a group of you
but i think there's some people who
definitely follow just you there's
definitely people who follow just kevin
and it's also styles like you look at
news anchors like there's some people i
don't like listening to it could be a
tone of a voice it could be the way they
talk it could be the way they present
their viewpoint like you still are
adding your viewpoint to that thing so i
don't know that's true i don't think
it's like one person gets to cover it
and they yeah
yeah some of it though it really does
become outdated after a day yeah uh and
once everyone covers it people lose
interest i mean that's a question is
that worth doing all those is it oh yeah
for those topics yes because usually
those are the best performing videos for
24 to 48 hours and it keeps up that
momentum so it's just another thing to
throw another cog in the wheel you throw
it in there it does exceptionally well
it's not going to long tail at all but
that keeps people coming back yeah why
are you not doing shorts well because
i'm wearing jeans right now
[Music]
you guys
you don't like
you don't like short no form content or
what is it about it like making it
watching it it's for me it's the um
like time out of your day yeah and all
you want to focus on is pumping out the
next video on the main channel yeah the
the main channel is my prior if anything
is taking away from the main channel
it's just not worth my mental stress i'm
just thinking about i'm gonna give you a
hypothetical
um you hired a producer
i'll let you you pick in your mind your
salary that you pay them whatever take
deduct that
you have this producer and their job is
just
tick tocks short form content for you
and they run the t your tick tock or
whatever you're gonna make maybe a reels
channel
uh maybe it's and then shorts separate
channels
uh and if in in um if in two years that
was able to generate a million dollar
additional revenue opportunity for you
is that worth doing yeah how do you come
to a million dollars
um
[Music]
it would come in the form of eventually
i mean right now there's like funds
right yeah sure so those aren't going to
pay out
or but over time i would imagine there's
going to be a battle over creators and
their content
and uh so you have a little bit of
either the funds grow you also have
monetization and ads figured out at that
point and i imagine if you're doing
sponsorship deals you would have other
short form sponsorship deals you could
do yeah um so
that's how i'd come to that evaluation
i don't know
honestly if it takes away from the main
channel or stresses me out anymore like
i feel like at this point
i'm like
i i like i could only retain so much in
my head
and right now i'm at like 95 percent
capacity that's why
it could be a little sharky but it's
like hey
this is my goals for these channels this
is my goals for your job if you don't do
it sorry you're out because i have no
capacity to either train you they just
hang around follow me you figure out the
content and because they're people who
do that um
and are great yeah but it's but it's
even committing an extra hour a day to
filming something uh maybe not though
it's like okay that person would sit in
the corner of the room
listen to our conversation at the end of
it they would come up to you and and
just for you and jack and spit ball like
hey uh i think we should grab this one
tick tock with with zach um here's the
idea i think it'd be funny if like we're
by the aquarium whatever and can we go
shoot it 15 minute shoot at the end of
the interview and then that's the one
piece from the podcast
they watch your edit a few minutes
before it goes out or i don't know where
you process it it sounds like it gets
edited overnight do you review in the
morning
with alex's idea usually i'll edit the
same day's post by that point they've
watched it and when you're right after
you're reviewing with alex they grab you
for 10 minutes because they understand
the concept and they already knew from
the day before and they've got a quick
like they've written a 15 second version
in case
i don't have time as a viewer to listen
to your video of that i want the quick
snippet to almost kind of tease and see
if i want to watch it that would go on a
short channel but it actually you know
has little value
i would cons i would consider it i don't
know again like the person i'm
describing is like
fairly high level or they've done this
for another you know youtuber probably
or somebody um as a content creator or
they want usually that person wants to
be one themselves but doesn't like
rather tap into your audience and just
help you sure um and they're a fan of
you that would be yeah interesting i
would cons i would consider it but right
now i feel like like really 90 of
everything i do is the main channel so
like i feel like my time is probably
better spent spending that extra hour
doing something on the main channel part
of the million dollar exposure
or that value i'm giving it in two years
is also the accounting for the growth
that your channel would get
um the new eyeballs that would learn
about you
because again i'm thinking like this
whole thing
even finance youtube uh is so new
and early days and you need to be
captured like building that real estate
basically you know it's like beachfront
youtube real estate for you guys right
now that you're like building that
exposure and that's the exposure part
that's like even if they don't know your
name it's like oh i've seen him like
remember the guy that met you he's like
oh i've seen your videos actually he
didn't think he knew you yeah but like
though that's where like when you look
at platforms i'm always measuring like
oh shoot
they're giving like within a swipe you
can see all those shorts whether that's
here to stay you know who knows but like
that's what
scarce fascinates me
you know and the reason
i'm into shorts also i mean yeah be fair
my content is rather short so it kind of
works i would i would consider it but
i'm afraid of growing too quickly like
even bringing on alex was like a huge
thing for us like even even jack for me
was was huge yeah and then bring on alex
was another huge thing like mentally
it's it's tough it's tough for me so
like i would consider it yeah but it's a
it's a big ordeal to bring someone else
because then it's just another thing
that even if they do their own thing
it's just like that's taken my capacity
to 97 though yep yeah i already have
someone that is like they're not even
receiving compensation yet for it but
they are now clipping up and posting all
the iced coffee hour uh clips into tick
tocks they have like reels or something
ready uh he's clipping up graham's main
channel videos and graham's apprehensive
to post it on his tick tock but he's
open to the idea and this person's
clipping up his main channel videos like
into one uh you know the concepts into
one you know short tick tock or whatever
and we post it on gramm's technology as
well so it wouldn't necessarily require
any of graham's time
yep i think the clips are interesting
you can always unless you're shooting
extra wide it's hard like viewers just
know yeah there's something about like
seeing a clip you're like ah this is a
someone's repurposing like that's why i
think it really needs to be custom and
that's the stuff that does really well i
agree like it's just like they do it on
their phone they shoot it is it better
than nothing
i don't know really i
see i was kind of thinking it's better
than nothing but the idea would be doing
something new yeah i would agree it's
maybe better than nothing but it's
if you're gonna go through that work
like
you might as well shoot a few custom
pieces like we see a difference like we
don't do this anymore but we don't cut
down like if we shoot a video for tick
tock and also shoot it for youtube we
shoot it twice like it's a little ton of
work but we'll literally flip the camera
and shoot it horizontal and then we'll
shoot one vertical because
the framing matters like people can tell
the cut down is just always punching
yeah i could always tell and
it doesn't look good
that's really interesting yeah that
actually wouldn't i mean it wouldn't
require that much more time if the
person already said hey this is what we
needed
these are the video bites that i need
from you or whatever you could just flip
a phone vertically instead that's true
so that's really like if i were you guys
i would literally pay somebody to sit
here
on a knife or whatever dslr or iphone
manually just film the interview
vertical and like they'd have to really
be paying attention but like when we're
going over the
what's that what's the opener of this
going to be the cold open
is it going to be the breaking the
like what do you mean are you talking
about the
the cold open for like for the viktor no
for the iced coffee oh no he's gonna be
jack and i doing an intro yeah we're
gonna introduce you
oh oh you're you don't throw like a
little like an impulsive thing yeah no
we talked about doing why you should
have you tried it uh we did it uh a few
episodes
probably in like the 10th through 15th
episode probably dude try that again you
think so yeah i think that's really
really important
uh i don't hold on we gotta have a fake
argument for that
can we no
no here's what it is
no fake argument yeah i don't trust you
yeah
get out of here i don't trust you those
ones don't work fake arguments don't but
if i showed you like the reaction you
guys had to seeing the shorts the other
day yeah when i showed you it's that
you're like no way
like and if we actually talked about
that in depth like that's your that's
your opener yeah we always save you know
podcast so
i i think
you should maybe not this one but the
future one but what i was saying with
that person shooting vertical yeah like
they would be able to pick apart after
they've shot that and they're going back
and forth and you can tell it was like
in the room it was shot on a phone it
was vertical you're kind of leaning in
like wait what is what are they talking
about
that's like what's gonna make me then if
i see that
and there has to be again value in there
like i get the either you or i give the
guest
that valuable little tidbit that they
were kind of looking for but they know
there's a podcast that has way more then
i'm gonna go that podcast
you gotta hire someone to stand right
there
that's the only solution
yeah oh figure yeah we'll figure it out
we'll think we'll figure it out i don't
know if we will but that's right i know
chances are i know there's somebody
watching yeah or somebody watching yeah
that's what i think you put out hey if
you guys are fans of graham stefan he's
hiring
um you have to be super good because
he's really picky but uh he is hiring
and uh jack will and um
alex will go through the applications
where can they send you applications uh
alex nava at
go ahead you know what just you know
i'll go through a few not saying we're
gonna hire no okay here's here's the key
to the hiring video because you're
hiring a producer yeah we did this uh
and we were
blown away by the results we said
there's no applications don't send your
resume we don't want a list of things
you've done make you have 60 seconds to
tell us why we should hire you tell us
about you in a video in a video format
oh i like that all right guys all right
guys in 60 seconds why should we hire
you well so we got to have a title that
people can do no they would just be
emailing it
email yeah email literally email and
here's the test part of it is like make
that subject line the best title for
your 60-second resume that's the test
literally i like what we did when we
hired alex was we had people just title
their video gram stuff in interview and
then we got to watch them all and
everyone else got to watch what people
were saying you could do that too but
then other people prayed on our people
that tried to get the job because yeah
yeah it is smart but also not everybody
is comfortable like even putting their
stuff online uh yeah a few people wanted
to leave it on lists yeah so all right i
would just say take it privately and
i mean we were blown away by like it was
it was clear it was like
the 20 front runners come to the front
and you're like wow
all right okay so info at alexnava.com
alexander nova oh info at out we're
going to put it up on the screen listen
up everybody graham stefan and team is
hiring do you want to submit a video uh
an application they're not taking
applications they don't care about your
resume so they they want a 60-second
video
uh
shoot my hint is shoot it vertically too
because where this is social media
business um and then the subject of that
email right the catchiest title why they
should click on that because they're not
gonna even click on all of them well
thanks for coming on zach this has been
a pleasure and an honor to have you on
yeah seriously crazy i was watching you
on vine yeah when i was i don't even
know in middle school maybe which is
insane now yeah i'm actually sitting
across from you no no no no no but it's
just it's an honor thank you so much
yeah of course and uh if you guys
haven't picked up your bankroll coffee
yet go do so in the description just
think of it yeah be honest wait was it
that was your beans yes oh really good
yeah that i think was wizard creamer
here it's really sweet yeah so i did so
i put uh what is it uh captain not
captain crunch i usually cinnamon toast
cinnamon toast crunch you know
it's holiday flavor oh cool we'll go
pick up a go pick up a is it a is it
come grounded or is it all both okay
whole beans yeah pick up whole beans get
a grinder
wow that's good well thank you so much
man i really appreciate it and uh did
you get your free stock down below in
the description when you sign up for
public it's worth all the way up to a
thousand dollars what's public when you
use the code graham
they're stock trading your brokerage
that's social media profile platform
is
yeah that's the advantage of that's the
public advantage is that you could see a
profile see exactly what i find so
thanks zach nice all right thanks guys
great thank you